the biden administration is laser
focused on the issues affecting everyday
americans like how rhodes are racist
transportation secretary pete
butterjudge says the new infrastructure
bill will address that
can you give us
the construct of how you will
deconstruct the racism that was built
into the roadways that you talked to the
griot earlier i'm still surprised that
some people were surprised when i
pointed to the fact that
if
a highway was built for the purpose of
dividing a white in a black neighborhood
or if an underpass was constructed such
that a bus carrying mostly black and
puerto rican kids
to a beach or it would have been in new
york was was designed uh too low for it
to pass by but that obviously reflects
racism that went into those design
choices
trees can apparently be racist vice
president tom laharis asking nasa about
it
can you measure um trees because part of
that data that you're referring to
and it's an ej it's environmental
justice but you can also track by race
there are averages in terms of the
number of trees in the neighborhood
where people live
racist greg well i gotta say uh mayor
pete looks great clearly he's lost the
baby weight
this is the problem with the everything
is racist prism because you can apply it
to any everything and it's very
seductive because it makes the user seem
educated and clever when it's merely
kind of repeating something that you
already heard he just heard those
stories so he repeats it and it comes
out as wow this is really interesting
but it's actually not an original
thought but it's an acceptable thought
at cocktail parties the problem is with
this how does his policy or the policy
based on this affect the actual outcome
like where are you going to change the
bridges or the streets what if the
changes are actually really good for
everybody like what if they the
improvements on this racist you know
bridge actually is beneficial
why did you have to bring this up if but
if you don't have a specific solution
for this but you brought it up anyway
then it's a pretty obvious virtue signal
to appear thoughtful and and and
progressive and woke but i just i i i'm
interested to see when this is all done
where they're going to point to and go
see this was the this was the bridge i
was talking about the breast box
expressway i could point to it so what
do you do with it the question is you
don't use this money for social
engineering i mean that's the problem
that's what's disappointing to me
eisenhower's interstate system was the
grandest greatest public works project
there was or since the erie canal it it
opened up america for everybody it
benefited everybody rich people poor
people black people white people asian
people hispanic people everybody
benefited if we start with pete
butterjudge leading the way to point at
these projects like to change the bridge
over the corresponding stress rate which
works fine now
people have adjusted
instead of building new bridges or
repairing the bridges that exist and
tunnels and roadways and making wi-fi
available for everybody and it's going
to be in the hands of the same racially
oriented politicians that we used to
call poverty pimps when i was the lawyer
for the young lords poverty pimps they
work they they they jockey these
programs they find out what's happening
if you make this a social program a
social welfare program which is what
build better is supposed to be but if
you make infrastructure social welfare
what you're going to get is nothing at
the end of the at the end of the line
you're gonna have that money squandered
i have a theory about why buddha judge
would be talking about this now but it's
to greg's point anytime you like talk
about racism and call someone or a group
of people racist you're trying to get
them scared and to back off and to kind
of butt out and so dana i wonder to
toraldo's point it's because they want
power and control over that money they
don't want anybody to ask any questions
it's not going to get built on
taking down overpasses is going to get
built on things that aren't roads and
bridges and actual infrastructure well
also it says it's it's a billion dollars
to remedy so what's what's the remedy
right and and
that could also be said about the tree
issue and tree equity i understand what
you're saying like more trees in a place
is a good thing and if you look at a
place like i believe it's greenville
south carolina 25 years ago there was
this big push to put trees down the main
street and there was a big controversy
it was going to cost too much money now
it's like lovely because the trees are
built and
built the trees have grown up it's shady
it's a beautiful street to shop along it
benefits everyone and i think that
what the voters were saying last tuesday
is that we can support things that
support everybody but we don't want to
be put in these different categories we
might need to write some wrongs in the
past but then again the remedy as i say
here is going to actually benefit
everyone because we are we don't have
that society that like we used to have
jesse i did a deep dive on this no you
didn't do it
for me oh wow and what i found out that
yes race was a factor in some of the
design of the interstate highway system
granted but class was a much bigger
factor poor white and black
neighborhoods were carved up by this
highway system because it's much easier
to seize a poor neighborhood through
eminent domain you put the artery into
the downtown shopping district and the
artery out to the suburbs for the
commuters and that's how it's done they
went into german
italian jewish neighborhoods all white
people and they just carved them up how
many times have you heard the phrase
this poor white neighborhood on the
wrong side of the tracks there's always
a wrong side of the tracks and it's not
black it's not white it's about rich and
poor and that's how they did this so
just because we have to fix a part of
the system doesn't mean the system was
racist it just means some of it was
designed by idiots
most of the problems we have in this
country are because of idiots not
because of racists and what these idiots
are doing in the biden administration is
they're saying we're going to start
destroying highways and we're going to
replace these highways with mass transit
we don't want mass transit mass
transit's been on the decline for the
last 15 years we just came out of a
pandemic where people are leaving cities
people are working remotely the last
thing we need are more trains and
subways and buses so they're just going
to jam this down our throat what's going
to happen the big dig remember boston
they tried to rip up their whole highway
system and it took 25 years and the cost
was five times as bad and it just
created more drama and more
i don't know congestion which creates
more emissions so you're going to now
see a boondoggle a la the big dig in
every single city and every single place
where this build back but better uh
money is going to go and you're just
going to look back and you say jesse
waters was right
we did that all that time right to my
mind
damn that jesse was right oh he's right
always looking for the opportunity to
use the word boondoggle boondoggle i
love billion-dollar boondoggle yes say
it with buddha judge it's his it's
actually he looks great by the way yeah
he really does he really has left what a
bounce back usually it takes months but
you know i think he was on the treadmill
yeah he got the one treadmill they
couldn't get it
yes
i was about to make a joke and i am
editing myself because it would get me
in so
much trouble
ahead on the five democrats not learning
their lesson they can't stop smearing
parents